bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
internet.com ouest-france.fr 20
minutes.fr pour direct politique votre
émission politique sur Internet notre
invité ce matin et François Bayrou maire
de Pau et
président du modèle évidemment bonjour
François Bayrou merci d'être avec nous
ce matin dans direct poétique avec moi
sur ce plateau pour co-prés présenter
l'émission Les chalure Voix histoires
rédacteur en chef adjoint de 20 minutes
voilà chers internautes c'est le
principe de l'émission vous avez une
quarantaine de minutes pour interroger
François Bayrou réagir à l'émission je
me ferai un plaisir de retransmettre
votre question en direct
François Bayrou si vous voulez bien
commençons par l'actualité qui a marqué
cette nuit François Hollande
et le président
ukrainien toute la nuit à Minsk on parle
d'un accord en vue qui va être signé
dans les prochaines heures ça y est
peut-on dire enfin que l'espoir de paix
se concrétise vous y croyez ben ça on
verra parce qu'on ne sait pas s'il y
aura un corps alors est-ce que vous
faites qu'on se parle et on ne sait pas
ce qu'il y a dans cet accord
bon ce qu'on sait c'est que la France et
l'Allemagne ont pris une initiative et
c'est une initiative bienvenue en tout
cas on peut espérer de cette initiative
que quelque chose bouge qu'est-ce qu'on
va au bout du chemin trouver c'est ça la
question pour moi il y a à peu près deux
éléments de certitude le premier c'est
que
trois le premier c'est qu'on doit
retrouver les éléments du principal du
précédent accord de Minsk en dernier le
deuxième c'est qu'on doit respecter
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine
c'est-à-dire que
il faut qu'il y ait un cesser le feu et
il faut qu'il y a un retrait de toute
intervention russe
et le troisième c'est qu'il faut une
organisation intérieure de l'Ukraine qui
respecte les deux cultures les deux les
deux communautés de langues différentes
qui vivent sur le solde de l'Ukraine
donc une fédéralisation de l'Ukraine je
dis au passage parce qu'on est sur
Ouest-France et que Ouest-France est
tradition de pensée pour qui cette idée
fédérale a beaucoup compté puisque
pour moi qui suis
quelqu'un qui croit profondément que
l'Europe et l'avenir de nos nations en
gardant notre identité mais l'avenir de
nos nations le fait que
on ne sorte d'un conflit que par
une fédéralisation c'est-à-dire on fait
ensemble ce qu'on ne peut pas faire tout
seul et pour le reste il y a une marge
de liberté une marge de de
d'affirmation culturelle ce qui pour des
communautés dont l'une et russophones
russophone et l'autre est évidemment
plus ce sang plus attiré par l'Union
européenne et de langue
ukrainiennes tout ça c'est tout ça c'est
un élément et on peut être à peu près
sûr
que s'il y a un corps ce sera un accord
sur ces bases la question c'est
évidemment
où place-t-on les frontières en tout cas
où place-t-on pour pas employer le mot
de frontière les délimitations parce que
ces temps-ci le front comme vous savez à
beaucoup bouger les les
indépendantistes
ont en tout cas les partisans du
rapprochement avec la Russie on va dire
les choses comme elles sont ont
progressé et donc la question de la
ligne de front un territoire particulier
pour les territoires qui ont été annexés
disons par les je dis pas un territoire
particulier je dis que dans cette
Ukraine de l'avenir il faut que les deux
communautés vivent ensemble et que quels
aient une certaine marge de de
d'affirmation de notamment culturelle et
notamment de langue et notamment de
langue il y a il y a comme vous le savez
il y a eu une décision qui est une
décision lourde conséquences qui a été
de supprimer
le statut de langue officielle du russe
alors que évidemment l'Ukraine c'est
comme comme tous les pays charnières
c'est évidemment de communautés et au
fond la grande question du temps c'est
est-ce qu'on peut vivre ensemble en
ayant chacun son identité quelle lecture
faites-vous au-delà de l'Ukraine de la
stratégie de Vladimir Poutine
bon
Vladimir Poutine c'est un dirigeant
extrêmement
puissant en ce qui les soutenu par son
peuple
le soutien à la politique d'affirmation
de l'identité russe et du nationalisme
russe et de du retour de la Russie
retrouve chez les
citoyens russes dans le peuple russe un
écho très important
d'autre part c'est un dirigeant qui a à
l'esprit l'idée que l'essentiel est dans
les rapports de force et ceci pour moi
est un des grands enjeux de la
négociation que nous sommes en train de
vivre est-ce qu'il faut est-ce que par
tenez-moi je sais ce que vous allez
demander mais
finissons le avec cet aspect très
important le
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière tout ça
on dit Poutine est inquiet de l'Union
européenne et de l'extension de l'Union
européenne
et de l'OTAN
il faut que les dirigeants russes et
spécialement Vladimir Poutine
comprennent que s'il y a un ensemble qui
s'est construit au travers du temps sans
volonté de puissance sans volonté
d'impérialisme sans désir de contrôler
les autres cet ensemble c'est l'Union
européenne
sont le projet de l'Union européenne est
probablement dans l'histoire le premier
projet d'une puissance non impérialiste
les pacifiques d'une puissance dont le
but est la paix chez elle et la paix
avec les autres et la prospérité chez
elle et la prospérité des autres vous
inquiétez pas le mot peut-être ferait-il
sourire Poutine moi je pense que il est
très important de montrer et d'affirmer
clairement
que telle est notre volonté telle est
notre dessin
et donc il y a là
bon un enjeu évidemment très très
important est-ce que quand c'est
négociations il faut reconnaître
l'annexion de la Crimée par la Russie
comme semble pousser à le faire Nicolas
Sarkozy
évidemment la situation de la Crimée
mais on peut en chercher d'autres en
chirurgie
il y a là quelque chose qui a été une
violence faite au droit
et on peut pas effacer les violences
faites au droit d'un coup d'éponge sur
le tableau comme comme
on semble vouloir le faire cela dit il y
a une chose qu'il faut prendre en compte
aussi c'est la volonté des communautés
pour ne pas dire des peuples vous savez
la vieille idée du général de Gaulle le
droit des peuples à disposer de même
ce qui est une idée majeure pour nous
tous et il n'y a qu'une possibilité
d'articuler ces deux impératifs le droit
d'un côté et la volonté des peuples et
des communautés une possibilité c'est
une démarche de type fédératif de type
fédéral
l'idée que au fond
ça n'est pas si difficile de vivre
ensemble et de partager l'essentiel
chacun étant ce qu'il est assumant ces
son identité culturelle son identité
linguistique la la reconnaissance des
liens qu'on a des grands ensembles
reconnaissent si vous me permettez je
vais aller encore un peu plus loin je
vais faire un pas de plus
je pense depuis longtemps
que le jour où cette réalité là
s'imposera dans les zones de conflit on
vit ensemble mais chacun est responsable
au fond de ce qui tient à son identité à
son propre destin à l'intérieur de
l'ensemble pour moi c'est aussi la seule
possibilité pour que un jour au
Proche-Orient la paix se fasse c'est à
dire que je ne crois pas
à ce que nous avons essayé si
difficilement et avec tant d'échec
pendant 30 ans
entre les deux guerres entre la France
et l'Allemagne qui est le la coexistence
le voisinage on met un terme au conflit
et puis chacun chez soi je n'y crois pas
quand l'Europe
occidentale la nôtre est-elle sortie de
la guerre pas le jour où on a décidé
qu'il y aurait un armistice le jour où
on a décidé que désormais on vivrait
ensemble et que sur ces sur ces enjeux
absolument essentiels que sont l'énergie
ou les matières premières ou les règles
du marché ou
et bien nous désormais nous vivrions
ensemble nous déciderions ensemble c'est
pas la même chose le voisinage et le
choix de ce choisir un avenir commun ou
la volonté de se choisir un avenir que
va décliner cette cette pince élève
justement
à l'échelle de l'Europe mais vous voyez
bien qu'il s'agit d'une pensée
extrêmement
originale qui a son qui a son
identité c'est même une pensée
singulière absolument incomprise pendant
des années et des décennies en France
parce que en France chaque fois qu'on
prononce le mot fédéral alors on croit
qu'il s'agit de la volonté de donner le
pouvoir sur notre vie à d'autres c'est
exactement le contraire le l'idée
fédéral c'est que on va vivre ensemble
en partageant
des sujets essentiels et pour le reste
en assumant chacun notre identité notre
avenir notre histoire notre patrimoine
on passe à nous chapitre on ouvre la
politique économique et on va commencer
par une question d'ordre général avec
l'élection de type race vous savez a
fait beaucoup de bruit était très
commenté on parle de nouvelles pages de
souvenirs pour l'Union européenne est-ce
qu'on peut concilier et comment
concilier François Bayrou une politique
d'austérité une politique de maîtrise
budgétaire une politique de Carcans des
des dépenses
difficiles de la limitation de la dette
avec la logique du respect du suffrage
universel grec
grande question
est-ce qu'on peut faire comme si c'était
passé pour ma part je suis je ne suis
pas optimiste sur
le respect comme vous dites des
promesses faites au suffrage universel
par cyrisa partie
alors je vais je vais essayer de dire
les choses précisément comme je les
ressens
la manière dont ont été organisés les
relations entre la Grèce et ses grands
créanciers n'a pas été une bonne manière
la manière violente qu'on a imposée au
peuple grec je l'ai dit dans
d'innombrables émissions
pendant cette période pour moi était
porteuse de menaces et aujourd'hui
comme ça
sous la dénomination offensante de
troïka
des gens qui viennent de l'extérieur
avec leur
regard condescendant
et qui semble imposer au peuple ce qu'il
ne pas c'est évidemment quelque chose
sur ce qu'il faut faire en revanche
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut annuler ce
qu'il faut renégocier quelque chose pour
que cette émission se passe bien on va
se laisser finir les femmes et là on a
beaucoup de questions
on parle de choses qui sont absolument
essentielles pour la vie alors donc un
le peuple grec a subi une violence
réelle et symbolique les deux très
importantes
deuxièmement est-ce que les promesses
qui lui ont été faites peuvent être
respectées je ne le crois pas
pour une raison très simple la Grèce
comme la France
a besoin d'emprunter tous les jours pour
payer ses fonctionnaires et le train de
vie minimal qui est le sien
et de surcroît elle a fait des promesses
pour 12 milliards ou 15 milliards je ne
sais pas de de
d'augmentation des salaires de
recrutement des fonctionnaires tout ce
qu'on appelle
fin de l'austérité
et quand vous avez besoin d'emprunter
tous les jours pour vivre et que vous
allez voir votre banquier en disant je
vous préviens je viens de vous emprunter
de l'argent mais ne vous attendez pas à
le revoir parce que je vais pas
rembourser de ma dette mais le banquier
vous prête pas et c'est vrai pour le
banquier privé avec votre voisin si vous
allez lui emprunter 100 euros et c'est
vrai avec le banquier
de grandes dimensions que sont les
grandes banques et c'est vrai avec les
États et donc pour ma part
cette confrontation entre des promesses
qui exigent d'emprunter et d'un autre
côté l'annonce qu'on nous rembourse pas
et purement et simplement impossible et
donc il y a un pari économique
il y a deux issues dont l'une est
externes
dont deux
issues extrêmes l'une c'est on ne
respectera pas nos engagements et donc
il y aura une déception énorme parmi le
peuple grec et parmi tous ceux qui en
Europe on dit voilà la voie à suivre et
la deuxième c'est on sort de l'euro
voilà voilà les deux les deux issues
alors on espère qu'on trouvera un moyen
terme mais ce moyen terme sera de toute
façon décevant pour ceux qui ont cru que
quelque chose pouvait changer le
problème c'est que les également
successifs pas les derniers mais les
gouvernements précédents ont détruit
déstabilisé la situation intérieure de
la Grèce en ayant des contes publics
n'endettement qui était au-delà du
possible et et c'est là qu'on retrouve
nous pardonnerait de dire de revenir à
quelque chose que j'ai plaidé devant les
Français depuis 15 ans qui est que un
endettement excessif vous détruit comme
un ménage comme une entreprise justement
c'est aussi le cas pour un état en tout
cas supprime votre indépendance
venons-en à la France et à la politique
économique française vous aviez été très
critique en début depuis le début du
mandat de François Hollande ensuite on a
eu des baisses de charge le pack de
responsabilité aujourd'hui la loi Macron
est-ce que ces décisions là vont dans le
bon sens et ce qu'elles sont suffisantes
bon qu'il y ait un mouvement de réalisme
c'est certain et c'est heureux pas moi
qui vais dire le contraire vous vous
souvenez que c'est un mouvement que
j'attendais depuis le début depuis le
premier jour est-ce que ce mouvement de
réalisme est bien pensé et est-ce qu'il
suffit je crois pas que ce soit le cas
je pense qu'il n'est pas bien pensé
pourquoi parce qu'il est pensé dans le
cadre existant on change on ne change
rien si vous me permettez d'ouvrir une
parenthèse très rapide sur la dernière
conférence de presse de François
Hollande dernière conférence de presse
de François Hollande elle dit deux
choses elle dit je vais prendre une
initiative en Ukraine
premier point et deuxième point je ne
changerai plus rien
or cette deuxième affirmation qui est la
loi Macron suffit
au fond c'est c'est le dernier la
dernière étape et Dieu sait que la loi
Macron ne suffit pas et que c'est des
petits pas j'ai découvert à cette
occasion qu'il fallait une loi pour
qu'on puisse organiser des lignes de bus
je moi je pensais mais vous voyez à quel
point on en apprend tout le temps on en
apprend toute la vie je n'aurais jamais
imaginé qu'on ne pouvait pas organiser
des lignes de bus en France c'est une
grande noyalité mais c'est comme ça bon
alors ça c'est bien qu'on le
libéralise ou qu'on rend de possibles un
certain nombre de choses que que on
donne au maire le jour où ça se fera
c'est pas encore fait la possibilité par
exemple dans les centres-villes de faire
que les commerces fonctionnent pour que
le centre-ville soit vivant ce qui est
le cas d'une demande de de beaucoup de
maires de beaucoup de villes de beaucoup
de communauté sans que pour autant
toutes les grandes surfaces s'y mettent
si on avait une liberté de cet ordre je
trouverai ça très très bien mais est-ce
que ça suffit non pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement ne prend pas la mesure d'un
impératif qui est pour moi
la condition même de la vitalité et de
la créativité du pays nous sommes devant
des maquis des labyrinthes des jungles
de loi de règlement de normes de
contrôle de de toutes choses qui
empêchent les entreprises ou les
entrepreneurs ou les artisans ou les
commerçants qui les empêchent simplement
d'être dans l'idée du développement ils
disent non ben on veut pas prendre ce
risque embaucher créer quelque chose oh
ça va être tellement compliqué on va
avoir tellement de de comment dirais-je
de pyramides sur le dos de
contrainte plutôt que de coûts du
travail pour moi c'est essentiellement
une question de contrainte le
c'est pas vrai que le travail soit trop
payé en France c'est pas vrai on a au
contraire pour beaucoup de ceux qui nous
écoutent le travail est peu payé pour ne
pas dire pour beaucoup d'entre mal payés
alors les charges sont extrêmement
lourdes vous souvenez que j'avais
proposé toujours dans cette idée de
simplifier que pour un ou deux emplois
par entreprise on puisse simplement dire
on vous supprime les charges pendant
mettons 5 ans
histoire de lancer un coup de booster
bon c'était une idée qui essayait de
répondre de manière simple à cette à
cette observation là et donc
tant qu'on n'aura pas une démarche qui
soit une démarche
de de réécriture
avec une volonté de simplification
de tous ces codes énormes que aucun
artisan aucune PME ne peut connaître et
ne peut lire tant qu'on n'aura pas une
une
possibilité nouvelle pour le contrat de
travail tant qu'on n'aura pas le fait
que au fond il y ait plus de confiance
que de contrôle on a un point très
précis qui est abordé on parle de
lecteurs
vous avez déjà répondu mais il y a eu
des rebondissements depuis c'est celle
du boulanger qui souhaite ouvrir dans
votre région d'ailleurs 7 jours sur 7 à
qui on interdit par un arrêté vous avez
dit que vous souhaitiez qu'il puisse
travailler ainsi et la Confédération
Nationale de la boulangerie hier c'est
prononcer contre cette ouverture 7 jours
sur 7 en disant que les arrêtés
préfectoraux ne sont pas faits pour
empêcher les gens de travailler mais
pour trouver des équilibres promouvoir
la qualité des produits et instaurer des
règles équitables donc on voit que c'est
la profession elle-même qui freine des
quatre fers pour cette ouverture de quoi
s'agit-il parlons simplement de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit d'un artisan qui
veut ouvrir ou laisser son sa
boulangerie ouverte le dimanche
après-midi dimanche après-midi parce que
les boulangers sont ouverts 7 jours par
semaine
pas tous les boulangers de France sont
ouvert le dimanche matin
pas dans votre quartier en tout cas chez
nous les boulangers sont ouverts le
dimanche matin et en ville les blanches
sont ouverts le dimanche matin et donc
moi mon idée c'est que
chaque fois qu'il connaît dans une
entreprise
artisanale commerciale une famille
quelqu'un qui a quelques emplois
celui-là on le laisse autant que
possible développer son activité
comprenez c'est pas la même chose que
d'avoir
une une grande surface
avec tous les moyens que les grandes
surfaces ont et qui
décide que son activité sera ouverte 7
jours sur 7 c'est pas la même chose
quelqu'un qui est dans l'initiative qui
est assez d'inventer quelque chose qui
essaie de bon celui là qu'on le laisse
faire autant que possible il me semble
qu'en France on prend sans doute pour
répondre à des principes d'égalité qui
en théorie sont bienvenus mais traité de
la même manière le très grand
et le tout petit pour moi c'est pas de
l'égalité
encore une fois je vais pas ouvrir une
polémique avec la Fédération de la
boulangerie je comprends aussi que les
gens quand ils sont un ou deux disent
mais on va pas de me rendre
allons jusqu'au bout vous croyez que
c'est le dimanche après-midi qui vont
faire leur chiffre d'affaires
du boulanger vous croyez que c'est le
dimanche après-midi qui vont faire leur
chiffre d'affaires je ne crois pas ce
que j'ai l'impression que ce que ce
boulanger là qui est un entrepreneur un
petit entrepreneur avait à l'esprit
c'est une espèce d'image de marque qui
fasse que chez nous vous trouverez
toujours du pain et des gâteaux quel que
soit le jour et quel que soit l'heure
laissez le vivre mais je dis pas ça pour
ouvrir une polémique avec la boulangerie
pour le reste il y aura
99,9% des boulangers qui seront ouvert
le dimanche matin notamment en ville et
qui fermeront le dimanche après-midi et
ce sera le cas partout en Bretagne et ce
sera le cas chez nous en Béarn et ce
sera le cas partout vous voyez bien que
laissez-les vivre
laissez-les faire laissez-les innover
s'ils ont envie d'innover le c'est comme
ça que qu'une société qu'une économie
avance
chapitre on va ouvrir le chapitre qu'on
a consacré à l'Union nationale et
l'esprit du 11 janvier et au péril de la
montée du Front national il nous reste
plus que deux ans et demi avant la
prochaine échéance présidentielle
comment concrètement empêcher le Front
national de arriver au second tour
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire aux électeurs
du Front national pour les convaincre
alors je vais excusez-moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose de j'ai lu
un dirigeant socialiste qui a dit j'ai
honte et j'ai peur
moi c'est 2 sentiments qui me sont
étrangers j'ai pas du tout ce genre de
jugement
le Front National a prospéré sur les
impuissants et les blocages des
majorités successives et de nos
institutions et encore le mot
institution est un mot très large mais
sur le fait que en France
50% du corps électoral n'est pas
représenté dans la vie parlementaire
et là vous souhaitez une forme des
institutions sur ce point là je j'y
viens et donc simplement quand vous avez
ainsi
des gens qui sont exclus et bien ils
deviennent le réceptacle de toutes les
insatisfactions
est-ce que j'ai pour autant la moindre
indulgence à l'égard du Front national
aucune pour une raison qui alors est
extrêmement précise je considère que
les obsessions qu'il cultivent l'air de
rien
en faisant semblant d'employer des mots
qui ces derniers jours on a vu ça mais
en laissant entendre que au fond
au moins cela ils disent tout ose que
tout le monde pense tout bas
l'expression entre guillemets odieuse
qu'on entend si souvent parce que si on
pense tout bas il doit y avoir des
raisons pour lesquelles on dit pas tout
en Espagne
et des raisons graves
ces obsessions et ses propositions
sortir de l'Europe sortir de l'euro au
fond les mêmes que que Syriza en Grèce
raison pour laquelle Marine Le Pen a
soutenu l'extrême gauche grecque on voit
de
soutenu explicitement l'extrême gauche
grec cela
c'est le malheur de la France mais là il
y a urgence monsieur bayrouz
c'est-à-dire que François Hollande a
fermé la porte à une réforme des
institutions l'autre jour dans sa
conférence de presse les résultats
économiques ne seront pas mirobolants
comment fait-on pour contrer le Front
national est-ce qu'il faut une
candidature unique de la droite et du
centre
et comment vous avez dit François
Hollande a annoncé qu'il ne changerait
plus rien à nos institutions c'est une
grave erreur et c'est même une faute
c'est y compris une faute contre
lui-même puisque son programme il le dit
dans ses promesses annoncé aux français
c'était qu'il changerait quelque chose
alors on dit nos institutions moi je
suis pas pour un changement dans nos
institutions
je suis pour un changement de loi
électorale la règle électorale française
qui est une règle dangereuse et on
risque de s'en apercevoir
cette règle-là elle exclut
un très grand nombre de Français de la
représentation or s'il y a une
représentation nationale s'il y a un
parlement de écouter bien le mot
Parlement
c'est pour que toutes les grands
courants du pays y soient représentés or
l'extrême gauche l'extrême droite et le
centre ne sont pas représentés dans ces
institutions pour être représentées en
France il faut aller baiser la babouche
du Parti socialiste ou de l'UMP si vous
allez faire allégeance si vous vous
prosternez
si si vous êtes
si vous acceptez le rôle de route
secours alors on vous fait une place
même si vous pesez rien électoralement
mais la réalité celle là aujourd'hui
donc comment fait-on et devient ma
question alors et donc le le
s'il y a un impératif c'est de changer
la loi électorale en tenant la promesse
que François Hollande a faite au moment
de son élection d'introduire une part
substantielle de proportionnelle
comme vous
dans un média qui est un média de
liberté disent vous imaginez bien que ça
sera pas fait si deux ans c'est peu
probable mais François Hollande
est-ce que vous ne pouvez pas comme
observateur et moi comme acteur du jeu
politique français dire mais vous avez
fait une promesse cette promesse elle
est vitalement consacrée par la réalité
et alors pourquoi ne tenez-vous pas je
vais vous dire quelque chose
si on continue comme ça c'est le scrutin
majoritaire
qui va régler la question
en faisant des vagues vous savez
majoritaire la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase vous avez un vase qui
se remplit et puis il y a une goutte
d'eau et alors le vase déborde c'est
votre désaccord avec Alain Juppé ça
d'ailleurs
enfin nous en avons beaucoup discuté
ensemble et je pense et je crois qu'il
n'est pas éloigné de cette idée que on
peut si l'on est si fortement attaché à
l'idée de majorité je veux dire pourquoi
je suis un peu en désaccord on peut
trouver des moyens pour avoir
l'expression que j'ai utilisée c'est à
dire une part substantielle qui
représente tous les courants d'opinion
dans le débat national on peut avoir pas
je vais dire une idée simple on peut
avoir un scrutin majoritaire sur les
deux tiers des sièges et une
représentation proportionnelle sur un
tiers des sièges ce qui permettra de
compenser les
le comment dirais-je caractère
anti-démocratique du scrutin je reviens
je reviens à ma question sur 2017
néanmoins parce que elle se posera elle
se pose déjà de toute manière donc
comment fait-on pour contrer Marine Le
Pen est-ce que on fait une candidature
unique de la droite et du centre ou
est-ce que chacun part de son côté ça
dépend
qui
veut incarner
cette
entente
je l'ai dit il y a des gens qui peuvent
qui ont la possibilité la faculté le
caractère l'expérience le nécessaire
pour que une large entente se fasse et
il y a au contraire des personnalités je
vais pas entrer dans les noms il y a des
personnalités qui au contraire sont
organisent
on a compris la confrontation et
l'agressivité
c'est pas la même chose
vous limitez à deux je ne sais pas ce
qui va se passer je vais vous dire
vous vous participeriez à une primaire
on va pas parler de nom Vous
participeriez à une primaire ou vous
comment dire vous sacrifiez pour que
quelqu'un dont qui a votre faveur puisse
gagner
je n'ai pas d'attrait particulier pour
ce que j'appelle primaire
pourquoi parce que les primaires je les
dis à la Juppé souvent le risque des
primaires c'est qu'elle favorise le
noyau le plus dur du camp si le noyau le
plus dur du camp pèse 1
dans un ensemble qui pèse 10
son poids
n'est pas aussi déterminant mais si pèse
un dans un ensemble qui pèse 3 ce
moment-là il devient
déterminant c'est là que le choix se
fait et une élection primaire parce
qu'elle sélectionne ou en tout cas elle
prend un petit nombre de Français qui
vont voter même si c'est 3 millions 3
millions c'est peu même si c'est 4
millions 4 millions c'est pas énorme sur
l'ensemble du corps électoral français
une primaire le risque qu'elle fait
courir c'est que les plus dures pèsent
plus ce qui s'est passé
Hollande émerge
ici parce que vous remarquerez que
Montebourg avait
rejoint François Hollande
qui avait fait 17% de mémoire à
l'intérieur de la primaire c'est lui qui
rejoint François Hollande et d'une
certaine manière qui a fait la
différence et donc et puis les
circonstances avec l'affaire
Strauss-Kahn était pas tout à fait les
mêmes mais peut-être vous avez raison on
va voir
si Alain Juppé gagne ce Paris et bien
j'en serai pour ma part très heureux
très heureux et je l'aiderai
de quelle manière c'est ça et bien
jusqu'à renoncer vous
si alors on en a pas discuté de manière
précise puisqu'on n'a jamais fait à la
Juppé moi de négociation mais si elle a
un Juppé était choisie oui je pourrais
évidemment m'entendre nous pourrions
nous le ce courant
démocrate du Centre français oui nous
pourrons
à des primaires la création d'un
mouvement peut-être plus clair de la
gauche de l'UMP le centre voir la droite
du PS alors d'un mouvement je sais pas
si c'est le mot mais
vous savez quel est mon idée elle est
affirme mais chaque fois que je peux
aucun des problèmes du pays ne peut se
résoudre dans l'affrontement des deux
camps
des soi-disant de camp
ils disent qu'ils sont des camps mais
ils sont pas des cons donc la droite est
coupée au moins en deux la gauche est
coupée au moins en deux et
seul un ensemble au centre qui soit
réformiste qui soit si possible
compréhensive de ce qui se passe dans le
pays qui ne passe pas son temps à
exciter les gens les uns contre les
autres qui au contraire essaient de voir
ce qui rassemble et puis qui trouve des
mots différents et un enthousiasme
différent et une manière de de faire de
la politique différente qui soit pas
perpétuellement dans les privilèges dans
dans la dans la mise à l'écart dans le
fait de jouer avec les règles
perpétuellement
considéré que la loi est pas la même
pour ceux qui sont au pouvoir et pour
les autres tout ça cette manière
inédite dans nos institutions de
pratiquer la politique c'est une
nécessité pour le pays
le seul secteur sur laquelle puisse
s'organiser le jour où ça deviendra
possible par le changement de la règle
électorale seul secteur ou puisse
s'organiser une vraie majorité une
respiration est-ce que toutes les autres
sont des fausses majorité une aspiration
poétique notre nouvelle entre l'UMP et
le PS rassemblant les gens qui peuvent
être convaincus sur cette ligne de l'UMP
il faudra accomplir l'omelette de
l'expression Alain Juppé l'a utilisé
mais
il a cassé des œufs pour faire il faut
casser les oeufs
c'est pas mon idée mais vous voyez bien
qu'il y a cette solution il y a un seul
courant possiblement majoritaire
c'est celui qui en effet pourrait unir
les réformistes qui soient à la fois
raisonnable et enthousiaste des deux
camps des deux soi-disant quand et donc
eu une primaire ça suppose un accord
politique entre quelques personnes de
bonne volonté ardemment modérés c'est la
cinquième république moi je ne crois pas
que la primaire ce soit la Cinquième
République mais j'ai un débat vous le
savez avec Alain Juppé sur ce point on a
une différence d'appréciation ça nous ça
nous fâche pas pour autant parce que au
fond il a fait ce choix par affection
pour l'UMP c'est c'est son bébé de même
que les mouvements du centre sont les
miens j'y suis viscéralement attaché
c'est son
qui dit mais au fond le pouvoir exécutif
il ne vient pas de combinaison
parlementaire comment voudrait nous le
faire croire pouvoir exécuter il vient
du soutien que le peuple accorde a une
vision portée par une femme ou par un
homme c'est ça le c'est ça le contrat de
la Cinquième République ce contrat je le
crois juste ça vous surprendra peut-être
venant d'un homme du centre simplement
je pense qu'il faut qu'il soit à ce
contrat rénové par un changement assez
profond de la pratique
humaine fait dans votre hypothèse qu'il
y aurait plein de candidatures et que
Marine Le Pen serait à coup sûr au
second tour d'abord je signale qu'avec
tout ça est lié enfin soit dit enfin si
les sondages ont raison elle y est
et encore une fois
se servir du Front national comme
épouvantail pour
empêcher tout renouvellement de la vie
politique française ça n'est pas mon
point de vue à mon François myroux je
n'ai pas l'intention de me laisser
épouvanté par les épouvantails
une
comment une vision qui soit
dynamique
qui soit un renouvellement dans l'avenir
de la vie politique française une
question de régisse où est l'alternative
François Bayrou est-ce que vous pouvez
travailler main dans la main avec
Jean-Christophe Fayard nous pouvons
travailler ensemble je crois que
Jean-Christophe Lagarde de la vie hier
sur un média
et je le dis devant vous nous pouvons et
devons travailler ensemble alors la
différence ou le problème c'est que les
uns sont plus proches de l'UMP les
autres plus indépendants mais pour moi
le centre il ne peut être qu'indépendant
autrement c'est pas le sens
travailler avec François Bayrou à
condition qu'il n'est pas le cul entre
les deux chaises je cite est-ce que vous
avez le cul entre les deux chaises
est-ce que vous êtes clairement dans
l'opposition Hollande ce sont des
expressions qui sont pas adaptées à la
situation surtout pour quelqu'un qui a
l'habitude de prendre des risques
je pense pas qu'on ait pu dire que
j'étais hésitant dans dans
la responsabilité politique j'ai pris
plus de risques que aucun
des responsables politiques français
peut-être est-elle des risques en tout
cas je ne regrette aucun et donc le
ce type d'expression n'est pas juste
mais pour moi c'est très clair je
n'approuve pas la manière dont le
gouvernement et l'exécutif et le
président de la République ont traité
les grands problèmes du pays ces
dernières années je pense que les choix
qui méritaient d'être fait et les mots
qui méritaient d'être trouvé ne l'ont
pas été concrètement pour les élections
départementales avec qui le modem
doit-il s'allier est-ce que vous avez
une idée d'une on fait la proportion
d'investiture avec l'UDI avec l'UMP dans
la plupart des cas ce sont des alliances
dans l'opposition qui sont faites
et puis le reste c'est avec des divers
comme on dit des gens qui qui refusent
les étiquettes et c'est vrai que le
modem de ce point de vue là manifeste
une liberté et une indépendance et il
est vrai aussi que le la manière dont la
majorité
conduit le pays ne correspond pas à ce
qu'on appelle national avant second tour
à voter pour les candidatsump dans le
cas de duel umpps
systématique où ça sera au cas par cas
absolument pas là parce que si vous
connaissez les élections départementales
et si vous regardez la composition des
tickets très rare sont les cas où c'est
investiture
UMP ou investiture modem ou avec non
c'est pas comme ça que ça s'organise on
essaie de trouver dans les cantons y
compris dans les Pyrénées-Atlantiques et
j'en suis sûr en Bretagne les meilleurs
personnalités et c'est pas facile à
trouver parce que cette élection a au
moins le mérite de faire ce renouveler
une partie du personnel politique par la
féminisation mais
c'est moins partisan
ma démarche politique elle est moins
partisane que celle qu'on me recommande
toute dernière question François Bayrou
on a beaucoup de gens qui se posent des
questions sur cette affaire cette
polémique au sujet du président des
Jeunes Populaires
UMP qui qui n'a plus de titre de séjour
Stéphane Le folliat déclaré l'assemblée
que l'UMP était rattrapé par elle-même à
force d'instrumentaliser les questions
d'immigration est-ce que vous partagez
cette analyse et ce qu'il faut
naturaliser ce
il y a quelque chose d'un peu ironique
dans cette affaire c'est c'est elle est
pris qui croyait prendre
un garçon qui t'a presque j'ai lu
l'occasion de le rencontrer je savais
même pas qu'il existait pour tout dire
un garçon qui se manifeste fortement
contre
l'immigration et les sans-papiers et qui
lui-même se retrouve convaincu de l'être
bon en même temps
j'aime pas qu'on cible des personnes
comme ça j'aime pas qu'on cible c'est un
jeune garçon qui a été pour le moins
imprudent sans doute un peu pris par
l'ivresse
de la responsabilité entre guillemets
politiques
et d'avoir été choisi par Nicolas
Sarkozy et bon on découvre après coup la
situation qui est la sienne alors j'ai
pas envie de me perdre en commentaire
éternel sur une sur cette petite
ironique à faire très bien ce sera le
mot de la femme bon merci beaucoup
François Mayo d'avoir été ce matin
direct politique merci à tous merci
chers internautes on se retrouve mardi
prochain nous recevrons Jean-Christophe
Lagarde à 8h30 d'ici là restez connectés
à très bientôt